[Aplausos]
según el presidente turco turquía está
batiendo récord tras récord en términos
de crecimiento y exportaciones ha salido
de la pandemia más fuerte que antes y
está ascendiendo en las clasificaciones
mundiales
turquía a diferencia de reino unido no
sufre escasez de gas y nadie hace fila
para comer como en francia
así es como erdogán describe la economía
de su país pero en este mercado de
pescado de estambul sus declaraciones
suenen vacías
[Música]
en europa la gente busca comida en la
basura o al menos eso es lo que dice
nuestro presidente
pues que venga aquí y vea la población
real para que vea cómo le va a la clase
media turca porque ya no hay clase media
turca
el poder adquisitivo de la gente ha
disminuido vemos que nuestros clientes
tienen problemas de dinero
así que para nosotros el trabajo es
definitivamente más difícil la lira
turca ha perdido un 18% de su valor
desde principios de año lo que la
convierte en la moneda de las economías
emergentes con peor comportamiento del
mundo las cifras oficiales indican que
la inflación se aceleró en septiembre a
su mayor ritmo en dos años y medio el
mercado inmobiliario también se ha visto
afectado y la alcaldía dirigida por la
oposición afirma que los precios
promedio de los alquileres mensuales han
subido un 66% durante la pandemia y no
hay señales de que esto vaya a cambiar
hoy en día esta propiedad está en el
mercado por 7 mil 508 mil liras al mes
eso es entre 780 y 830 dólares y hace
uno o dos meses se ofrecía por unos 520
dólares la situación económica está
impactando los precios y seguramente
sigan subiendo en el próximo período
entre los más afectados están los
estudiantes que cada vez son más debido
a la apertura de cientos de nuevas
universidades privadas en todo el país a
finales de septiembre decenas de ellos
lanzaron un movimiento de ocupación de
parques y jardines públicos la
iniciativa llamada no tenemos
alojamiento fue rápidamente condenada
por el presidente turco de una forma que
se ha convertido recurrente en sus
discursos
los que se han instalado en parques
jardines y bancos esos últimos días son
realmente estudiantes
daniele son terroristas que vienen de
afuera a sembrar el terror igual que los
del parqué que sí
pregunta y usted es un terrorista
que venga a verlo por si mismo en las
calles en los parques luego si quieres
seguir llamándonos así es cosa suya
yang denis es un estudiante de derecho
de 23 años comparte en su pequeño
apartamento dúplex el dormitorio y
trabaja como mesero para pagar su parte
de la antigua chuches de trabajo por la
noche como mesero porque no tengo otra
alternativa en turquía hay millones de
estudiantes como yo que tiene que
trabajar aunque los empleos son escasos
de hecho ese es el verdadero problema
como podemos estudiar si ni siquiera
podemos encontrar un trabajo para pagar
el alquiler
la paradoja turca en pocas palabras
mientras el país está batiendo récords
su población se está empobreciendo
las cifras de crecimiento no reflejan lo
que ocurre en las cocinas de la gente ni
en lo que respecta a sus ingresos hay
una diferencia increíble entre lo que la
gente vive y gana y las cifras oficiales
lo importante es lo que gana la gente y
ahí no podemos hablar de crecimiento los
resultados son incluso más bajos de lo
esperado ahora mismo estamos en 'números
rojos'
el partido de la justicia y el
desarrollo de erdogán era el partido de
la juventud del futuro y del presente
crecimiento económico 20 años después y
con las elecciones generales de 2023 a
la vuelta de la esquina la posición del
presidente es más frágil que nunca